[Musica]
[Applauso]
tutto è un da tranne ciò che è
particelle e quello che è che non è
contemporaneamente ma queste sono cose
da nerd quantistici che non ho mai
capito e quindi facciamo che tutto e
honda bene ora che ho detto l'unica cosa
intelligente che so posso fingere di
avere un sacco di argomentazioni a
riguardo e altre idee profondissime e
parlare per quattordici minuti senza
dire nulla
come faccio sempre ma gesticolando in
modo che sembri che io abbia realmente
pensato a tutte le cose che escono dalla
mia bocca
cavolo mi è andato un palco un quarto
d'ora di tempo è una piattaforma che può
arrivare ovunque a chiunque io sveglio
il mio trucco alla seconda frase invece
di dire tutte le cose pseudo
intelligenti che ho imparato ma in
realtà è vero questo è realmente
semplicemente tutto quello che faccio io
dico cose le incastro in castranti
costrutti che non tutti capiscono ma che
belli o brutti carpiscono l'attenzione
danno illusione di illuminazione prima
di svanire in vapore di parole vuote ma
argute argomento sempre ciò che dico per
questo ricomincio da capo
l'essere honda non è la sola cosa che
avrei da esporre ovviamente è che vorrei
imparare a far sentire davvero le idee
che ho da dire riuscire a trovare il
modo di renderle vive vivide nell'iride
irrorare aridi arti con l'arte di
esprimere e il primo concetto su cui son
certo di volermi concentrare che altro
vuoi che sia se non la poesia
ecco per me la poesia e poesia quando è
poesia di poesia semplice chiaro lineare
spiego
perché qualcosa ci piace e qualcosa no
diciamo spesso che cose o persone sono
sulla nostra lunghezza d'onda ecco è
solo e soltanto questo la frequenza di
consonanza se il resto non ti resta
dentro ma una fondamentale a zona con la
forma mentale del sono hai trovato un
tesoro prezioso che non apprezzo
disprezzo chi pretende di
universalizzare il proprio sentire
non potrai mai dire questa è poesia per
chiunque perché sia monde diverse e i
versi che ci fanno vibrare possono
variare
non solo da persona a persona ma anche
da momento a momento davanti a un
tramonto che mozza il fiato da quanto
lento e continuo è il mutamento di
colore calore sapore del sole le sole
parole che possono venire solo di
stupore ecco ora prova a trasporre in
scrittura la poesia che hai e spirito
perché il tramonto la poesia primigenia
la fonte di onde di ispirazione da una
parte c'è chi i tramonti non li sopporta
perciò non importa impronta sonora non
trova sponda ma chi ama quel l'onda di
piena che è un panorama che richiama e
ricama ricordi non potrà mai analizzare
riportare pedissequamente ogni istante
in cronaca asettica di immagine statica
se vuoi mettere in poesia una poesia la
tua poesia deve essere poesia per
qualcun altro
devi trovare il modo di far sentire quel
che hai provato assaggiando il tramonto
per questo non mi monto la testa e non
dico di esser poeta se quello che scrivo
ti è un po poesia avrò fatto la mia
rivoluzione
e questo vale per il teatro una canzone
per ogni emozione per mille milioni di
situazioni diavolo prima pensavo di non
aver nulla da dire invece ora non mi
bastano questi pochi minuti
scusate munitevi di pazienza e
attenzione perché nonostante io sia
soporifero sono
cattivo ma pigro ansioso ma calmo colmo
di rabbia e pacifico girovago e fermo mi
informo ma ho pensieri informi insomma
sono honda sono mare sono mappa
ma partiamo da quel che ho imparato
l'amore come l'anima ed io ce lo siamo
inventato e tanto quanto la poesia non
puoi dire cosa sia per chiunque e quindi
inventiamo lo bello non litigarello
tossico complesso basato sul possesso il
sesso è stupendo finché lo è per tutti
gli esseri coinvolti e quei molti
esaltati coivolti turbati da gusti
assurti a postulati si son dimenticati
della fortuna di essere nati se qualcosa
esiste non è contro natura e può fare
paura o essere un male se letale per
umano o animale ma le malelingue battono
perché non hanno altro da fare
puoi colmare i tuoi vuoti colmare di
infiniti racconti raccolte di saggi
raggi di sole parole parabole favole per
eoni puoi perderti in aneddoti adatti ad
ogni situazione ma è l'azione la miglior
soluzione all'indecisione il danno
peggiore è il non sapere parlare e
chiarire se in positivo o in negativo
finché non è in positivo importa poco
che se ferisce più la lingua della spada
il silenzio uccide quindi uscite di qui
e di te l'amore
apritevi a nuove esperienze nutrite la
mente pensando sempre al bene comune
ma con una visione di insieme perché il
mondo non è solo bianco o nero
lo spettro è perfetto perché è pieno di
grigi e seppur completo non è mai
compreso per intero l'intento
dell'intelletto e permetterci di
allargare gli abbracci per metterci in
pari non marciano più celeri
impariamo a fermarci che le maree sono
belle anche per le pause tra l'una e
l'altra e le pause sono belle
e perché poi finiscono e finire è bello
perché poi si è liberi di fare altro è
essere liberi e il bello dell'essere
vivi la libertà come l'anarchia non è
l'assenza di regole o freni ma è
scoprire l'essenza di tutto e aiutarsi a
far bene le leggi migliori sono le più
liquide e qui devi sapere che oltre a
bere e mangiare andare di corpo e amarsi
il quinto piacere piacere più grande e
l'imparare e se pure io sia qui a
blaterare l'unica cosa che penso che
continua a pensare è che non so
abbastanza da potervi insegnare alcunché
e allora perché sto parlando
forse chi mi ha chiamato qui sta
raschiando il fondo o forse rischiando
ha fregato tutti stordendoli di parole
però ora che posso perorare cause e dire
ciò che voglio
cerco di vagliare e convogliare tutto
quello che spesso non si può esternare
ho detto che l'amore è un'invenzione
ecco per me un essenza superiore non
esiste si sta e fa bene anche senza la
speranza della sopravvivenza umana e
nella scienza non in qualche credenza
che pretende di avere il potere sulla
coscienza con dei perché sì senza alcun
fondamento non mento se dico che ci
illudiamo di avere uno scopo lottando
per salvare il mondo che se la cava da
solo non serviamo a nulla e non abbiamo
senso e questo può essere un peso lo so
ma può anche darti il motivo stesso per
cui fare tutto che è brutto e lo dico
spesso ma siamo un caso e quindi perché
non possiamo sfruttare ogni attimo per
seguire il bello e non parlo di quello
puramente estetico e soggettivo perché
la scala di giudizio figo sfigato non ha
alcun valore e il discrimine peggiore
che si potesse inventare
non che io trovi ragioni nelle
inveterate di
tensioni istintive trapelli che
belligeranti ribadiamo da aeree ma è
accettare che il male di avvii ad altro
male e cedere al peggio senza
intervenire come quando sentì dire lo
sai com'è fatto se lo può permettere
per mettere le cose in chiaro vogliamo
ammettere che il male è sempre una
scelta
facciamo tutti lo sforzo di andar contro
all'istinto
ma perché se uno stronzo fa lo stronzo
viene giustificato
mi oppongo espongo il problema
il male è facile ed è fragile chi lotta
per stare fermo nel decidere il bene
abbiamo tutti il nostro inferno in fondo
all'interno ma nessuno al diritto di
infliggerlo agli altri perché se un
carattere forte prevarica chiunque siamo
tutti tenuti accettare si crede normale
che rimanga tale quale promessa questo
mondo chi ha infranto per farti
svegliare incazzato ogni giorno e
imporre agli altri la tua frustrazione
sei responsabile di ogni tua azione e
reazione esattamente come ogni altro
essere di ogni nazione
a proposito anche queste sono
un'invenzione quando abbiamo intenzione
di scioglierle e dall'altra parte se uno
se qualcuno si sforza di scegliere il
bene ogni tanto tenta di riprendere
fiato è un ingrato
mi sorprende mi deludi non ti facevo
così siamo gli errori che non ammettiamo
e accettarci è ancora e sempre lo
scoglio maggiore per me è la regola
aurea è da aggiornare anche solo per
semplice aggiustamento matematico non
trattare il prossimo tuo come te stesso
ma prova a far meglio che se uno dei due
è uno stronzo avrai compensato il
divario che separa dal giusto questo è
il senso che woody ha messo in basta che
funzioni le utopie restano tali
perché noi non siamo esseri umani
domani davanti ai tanti quesiti che vi
verranno impartiti da partiti petizioni
patiti perizie pulsioni punizioni
pandemie passioni persone provate a
pensare a che parte del boe dell'onda
volete che segua ogni minimo scarto
dal passato al futuro è racchiuso
nell'ora e in quel che credete credete
sia meglio e niente è dovuto se non il
rispetto ogni filo di vento che siete
diventa increspatura sul pelo dell'acqua
fino che non si espande a tutto lo
stagno avete in pugno il bene del mondo
e capisco il piacere di avere il potere
che porta a pensare a sé ea nient'altro
ma il nostro valore e quel che creiamo
siamo animali sociali non ci bastiamo
ma stiamo coi piedi per terra sempre
finché ci sarà aria visto che la stiamo
mettendo a ferro e fuoco come acqua
suono luce e sangue siamo on the fate
per restare a contatto con tutto e tutti
siamo quel che scegliamo di essere e se
credi che sia tuo diritto avere tutto
perché se sei nato dal lato giusto di un
patriarcato capitalista sappi che capita
esista sempre il rovescio della medaglia
che ti sei dato da solo una solo può
essere il migliore del mondo ma se
nessuno e all'ascolto andrà dissolto nel
vuoto e inoltre un voto dato a chi
discrimina e incita odiare è un crimine
inoltrare a oltranza
l'illusione l'istanza della legge del
più forte che porta a chiudere porte e a
perder cultura
in realtà la natura dell'essere umano e
tendere la mano non sono nessuno ma se
posso avvisarvi visa v vi state scavando
la fossa da soli voi stronzi perché
anche se frivolo inutile effimero il mio
piccolo e umile obiettivo
e che all'arrivo quando anch'io avrò
finito i miei battiti altri animi affini
a sonino in spartiti migliori signore e
signori
l'unico vero valore che abbiamo e il
respiro del ricordo che lasciamo
[Applauso]